Sridhar Komalla: Hey, here! And I welcome you all to my next session. Saturday Lecture Series. And today's topic is mutual funds in this video. Let's quickly understand. What are we going to learn? Number one? We are going to talk about what is a mutual fund, its basics, and how it works. Number 2, we are going to learn what are the different types of mutual funds. Number 3. I'm going to tell you about a very specific type of mutual fund, which is a comparatively less known, or, I may say, less explored type of mutual fund.
Sridhar Komalla: and the last and the bonus tip from my side is what are the things that you should check out before investing in any mutual fund?
Sridhar Komalla: This video is brought to you by easy plan. Easy plan is an app that helps you save money regularly from your phone, where you can earn a higher return than your regular savings account, and these returns can also go close to your returns on Fds. And that, too, without any lock-in period. Easy plan helps you to invest in low risk liquid mutual funds. But do you know what's a liquid mutual fund? No, and watch this video till the end, so that you can get an amazing idea about exactly what is a liquid fund and how it works.
Sridhar Komalla: Okay, so let me just quickly tell you what is a mutual fund and how it works. Okay, to put it in a very simple way. Let's take a very simple example on this. Assume that I were to go from Pune to Mumbai.
Sridhar Komalla: I have 2 options assume. I can take out my own car. I can ride on my own. I can drive on my own I can enjoy because I know how to drive. I know what way I have to choose. I know what are the basic rules, everything. Okay. So I'm a well educated person as far as driving is concerned. So I can choose how to drive, which way to go and how to go. What
Sridhar Komalla: possibility? Number 2. I'm not really keen on driving. I just want to reach Mumbai. That's it. So what I can do is I can just hire a driver. I hire a professional. In short.
Sridhar Komalla: he takes the decision on which road to choose and what speed to drive, where to stop?
Sridhar Komalla: I keep all the decisions at his discretion. I just told him the final destination. Okay, that's exactly the difference between a stock market investment and a mutual fund investment
Sridhar Komalla: in stock market investment. You take your own decisions, you know where you have to go, how to go. You have expertise in that, and you have the enthusiasm, I may say, to explore these things, but if you're of the second category. You're really not bothered to explore things. You better hire professional, and he will take decisions for you. That's exactly what a mutual fund does. So in Simple words, Mutual Fund. There is a mutual fund manager
Sridhar Komalla: takes decisions on your own money which is invested with the mutual fund. Okay, so let's understand basically what a mutual fund does. Okay, it will
Sridhar Komalla: collect money from people like you and me. Okay, so assume that there is a there's a pool of 100 people. Okay. And these 100 people, given funds.
Sridhar Komalla: contribute some money to a mutual fund. Now this mutual fund is going to reinvest this money into different different investment opportunities, like a mutual fund, can invest in equity. A mutual fund can invest in debt. A mutual fund can invest in either or or both. Okay, so that depends on the objective of the Mutual Fund scheme. Okay? So
Sridhar Komalla: putting it in a very short, you know, nutshell, I may say mutual fund is nothing but a type of organization which would take money from people like you and me would create a pool of funds, and this pool of funds will be invested in different different investments. Okay.
Sridhar Komalla: now, what is the
Sridhar Komalla: positive side for the Mutual fund? Mutual Fund, which has invested in different different avenues? Investment Avenues Mutual Fund will earn income out of that.
Sridhar Komalla: Okay. Now, this income earned can be in the form of interest, or it can be in the form of dividend. Okay, it could be in the form of gain as well. Difference between cost price and selling price. Okay?
Sridhar Komalla: So mutual fund they got gains. Okay, assume they got ₹100 gains. Then what mutual fund is going to do with that? Distribute this to the investors, those who had invested in the mutual fund.
Sridhar Komalla: Do you think they want to distribute entire ₹100 if they distribute entire ₹100? Are they mad just to do social service? No, they're not going to do that, so they are going to take out some portion for their own purpose. This is exactly known as management expenses, or people call this as an expense ratio.
Sridhar Komalla: This expense ratio would be typically 1% to 3% of your total investment amount. Okay? I hope you have understood how a Mutual Fund works in a more simplified manner.
Sridhar Komalla: Move on to the types of measure funds
Sridhar Komalla: originally. What used to happen? I'll tell you every Mutual Fund company. I'm sure you might have heard about all these Icici Mutual Fund or Hdfc. Mutual Fund, or you might have heard about Bill Asson like mutual funds.
Sridhar Komalla: and they're in the market.
Sridhar Komalla: Every mutual fund used to come up with a different type of mutual fund, and they used to say, Now invest in this one, now invest in that one
Sridhar Komalla: poor investor used to get confused as to exactly where I should invest and where I should not. So what Sebi did.
Sridhar Komalla: So we said, you can have now only 5 types of mutual funds. Okay, which are the 5 types. Number one, we have an equity mutual fund. Okay? So let's understand what's an equity Mutual fund like, I explained. Right now, Mutual Fund
Sridhar Komalla: the Mutual Fund Institution basically is going to collect money from people like you and me, and this collector money will then be invested in equity will then be invested in stock market. This will be an equity oriented mutual fund, or an equity mutual fund.
Sridhar Komalla: Second, one is a debt fund. What? What will happen with a debt fund? Again? Same 1st step remains same. That mutual fund is going to collect money from people like you and me. But instead of investing in equity now, it will invest in debt. Okay, please understand, in debt. The risk is definitely on a lower side, because there are, there is nothing to do with the stock market fluctuations. This money from a debt debt fund never gets invested in a
Sridhar Komalla: stock market. Right?
Sridhar Komalla: 3rd one is known as a hybrid fund. Okay, Hybrid Fund. I hope you have understood by the name itself. It could be, a little bit of equity could be a little bit of debt.
Sridhar Komalla: 4, th one is basically a solution. Oriented fund solution. Oriented fund could be like a child marriage fund. Okay? Second, one could be, it could be a child education fund. Okay? So basically, it's a solution oriented you, you have a solution. You basically want a solution after some specific time frame for which you invest. And whenever the time comes you're going to take out money from that fund
Sridhar Komalla: right? Both type was a solution fund solution solution oriented fund, and the last one is like an other mutual fund. The 5th one is like other fund.
Sridhar Komalla: The best example of another fund is an index fund. Okay, so basically, an index fund. Whatever money this Mutual Fund House is collecting, it's directly invested in the fund. It's directly invested in the index. Basically. So they're going to invest directly in your nifty. They're going to invest directly in sensex, something like that
Sridhar Komalla: hope. You understand the basic types of funds.
Sridhar Komalla: So moving on today, we are going to focus only on one type or in that type. Also want to talk about a specific subtype
Sridhar Komalla: which is comparatively less explored by people like you and me. I'm sure everyone looks at mutual funds only from one angle. That is, I would like to earn more.
Sridhar Komalla: but I don't want as much risk as is involved in stock market, so majority of you, I'm sure, might be going ahead with equity oriented mutual funds. But, guys, is that the only option available for mutual fund? Answer is, no. So today, what we are going to talk about is debt fund. And in debt fund. Specifically, I'm going to talk about a fund which is known as a liquid fund. Okay? Now, what's a liquid fund?
Sridhar Komalla: Liquid funds are a type of mutual fund that invest in securities with a residual maturity of up to 91 days.
Sridhar Komalla: Assets invested are not tied up for a long time, as liquid funds do not have a lock in period. I'm going to talk about various perspectives of a liquid fund
Sridhar Komalla: another one
Sridhar Komalla: for whom liquid fund is useful. Okay, generally, people like me, poor people like me. I don't earn any salary guys. Seriously, I don't earn even ₹1 of salary. Okay? Or whatever income I get is business income or professional income. So what happens with me? And let us understand, maybe 10 days, 15 days. I might not even earn ₹1. But on the 16th day I might earn X amount of money. Okay.
Sridhar Komalla: now the question is, oh, my God! I've got that sweet message from Bank that your account has been credited with whatever rupees. Okay. But then I don't know what I'm going to do with this money. Okay, just an example. Assume that on a single day I got ₹40,000. Okay, but I'm not sure what I'm going to do with this ₹40,000.
Sridhar Komalla: But do I really keep this money in savings account?
Sridhar Komalla: That is one alternative, right? But in this I'm going to get only 4% return.
Sridhar Komalla: Instead of that, what I may think of is, let me park these funds temporarily in a liquid fund. Okay. Now, what a liquid fund does is that
Sridhar Komalla: it is a type of mutual fund which will park your money only for a short time. Short time. It could be even like one day, and it could be on a higher side. Okay, it should not be beyond 91 days. Okay, so in simple words, for whom liquid funds can be important. It could be for those people who get money.
Sridhar Komalla: They have some investable suppliers, but they're not sure when to invest or where to invest. They just need some time to think on where to invest for them. I feel liquid fund can be the best possible solution.
Sridhar Komalla: Second, if you talk about the returns on these liquid mutual funds, typically, whatever types of or whatever different schemes I just checked, it could be. The Icici potential scheme or other schemes as well. I found out that.
Sridhar Komalla: So I created this indicator which gives me buy and sell signals for any chart. Take a look at this when the bars change colors, it means that the indicator is detecting a new trench.
Sridhar Komalla: Typically, okay, majority of the cases, you earn a potential return of up to 7%. It's way too higher than your saving bank account. And it is also beating your fixed deposit returns. Okay? So I feel it's a amazing investment opportunity. I might not say that the returns are like sky high, but definitely, they are definitely higher than your savings account as well as your majority of these.
Sridhar Komalla: if I go to the next point, is liquidity. So let's assume that I had invested in this liquid fund, and I need funds. Now, I after, let us say, almost 7 days. Now, I'm sure. Okay, I need to invest my 40,000 in this specific area.
Sridhar Komalla: Do I immediately get my money or no answer is, yes. So typically, whenever I sell these liquid mutual funds, okay, I would get my money immediately. Okay, so I did talk about returns. I did talk about liquidity. Number 3 is, are we safe?
Sridhar Komalla: Will it eat up into my investments? Okay, so that is what I wanted to talk about certain precautions that you have to take before you invest, but that I'm going to cover in the last segment of this video only, but one more important aspect which you should understand because it's directly linked with one product, which is your returns. But next is what taxability?
Sridhar Komalla: There is someone who is actually looking out. Oh, you want the money. And who's that Government of India?
Sridhar Komalla: Okay? So what tax will be levied on my gains on liquid fund is a very important point. Please understand this. There could be a long term capital gain, or there could be a short term. Capital gain. If it's a short term, capital gain. What is a short term? Capital gain. I invested in a liquid fund, and I have
Sridhar Komalla: sold it within a span of 3 years. Okay. So I told you that one year criteria but one year criteria is basically for the instruments in which I'm investing. Okay? So
Sridhar Komalla: if I buy into a mutual Fund liquid Mutual fund, and I've sold it, let us say, within 8 months, as an example. Okay, I've sold it within 8 months.
Sridhar Komalla: Then assume that I got ₹10,000 as a return from this. Okay, now, this 10,000 will be taxed as per my tax lab. Okay, so if you think that my income is up to 2 lakh 50,000. Then I won't have to pay any tax on that. If you feel that my income is up to 5 lakh. Then I'll have to just pay 5% of this gain
Sridhar Komalla: if you feel that my tax lap is somewhere between 5 lakh to 10 lakh, I'll have to pay 20% tax on that. And just in case, if you feel that my income exceeds 10 lakhs, then I'll have to pay 30% on this same amount. Okay? So that's for what that's for a short term.
Sridhar Komalla: capital gain on a liquid fund. If it's a long term, capital gain on a liquid fund, then the taxation is flat at the rate of 20%. But there is a concept of indexation also involved. It's a little bit tricky. I might cover that, you know, separately. Okay, I hope taxation perspective is also understood.
Sridhar Komalla: Let's move on to the last segment, which is the precautions to be taken, and some bonus tips from my side as to at least 2 to 3 points which you should consider before investing in any liquid fund.
Sridhar Komalla: Number one check. What is the entry load or the exit load? Okay, see, guys, entry load is generally going to be 0 exit load will also be 0
Sridhar Komalla: for majority of the cases. But in some funds which I was checking on the Internet, there is an exit load. If you exit the scheme within 7 days of investing. Okay? So if you're investing today, and let us say you sell the units within 2 to 3 days, you might be charged with an exit load. So just check whether the exit load is there for the scheme or does not prevail for the scheme.
Sridhar Komalla: Number 2 also check what is a lock in period. See? Generally there is no lock in lock-in period for any liquid fund. Okay, at least, whatever research I did. There was no lock in period for any scheme. But
Sridhar Komalla: that should be a basic precaution that you should check before investing in any fund. And the last point very, very important.
Sridhar Komalla: I am investing in a liquid fund. Does this mean that there is 0 risk? As I mentioned, it's a very important point. Guys, please understand this point. Okay, is there a 0 risk involved in liquid fund? Answer is no, there is a risk for sure. See, the moment you are getting a little bit more return as compared to saving a little bit more return as compared to Md. That's a thumb rule of finance, high risk, high returns
Sridhar Komalla: the moment you're getting higher returns. It means that you are exposed to some sort of risk. Now, what would be that? Some sort of risk, you might say. But, madam, it's a debt fund. So there's no stock market risk. I agree there is no stock market risk
Sridhar Komalla: question is that where do this? In which instruments do these mutual funds invest. Okay? So going back to our 1st point, people like you and me invested in this mutual fund. Now the question is, where do this? Where does this pool of money go into this pool of money can be going into something known as certificate of deposits.
Sridhar Komalla: It could be going into commercial papers. It could be going into government bonds into Treasury bills. Okay, I'm sure all these are alien names for you. But if I start explaining each and every concept. The video will go like 1 h or something, something. So again, I'll discuss this separately in a different video. Okay, so these are different different names of
Sridhar Komalla: debt instruments as of now. Okay.
Sridhar Komalla: now, what could happen? I'll give you a simple example of one of the debt instruments here. One of the debt instruments I talked about is a commercial paper. Okay, let me repeat, it's a debt instrument. DEBT. It's not a death instrument. Okay? Right? I know it was a banjo. Okay, anyway. So death instrument commercial paper. It's a kind of an unsecured instrument.
Sridhar Komalla: What does it mean tomorrow? If some company who had issued this commercial paper, and that is a commercial paper in which this mutual fund is investing. That company was bankrupt
Sridhar Komalla: example. Yes, we do have an example.
Sridhar Komalla: Our favorite Islefs. Okay. Aislefs had come up with a promotion.
Sridhar Komalla: There were many mutual fund liquid funds who had invested in commercial papers of Iloquis.
Sridhar Komalla: Okay, what happened? Is there a risk for this liquid fund? Yes, there is a risk.
Sridhar Komalla: So ensure that not a big chunk of your liquid fund goes into a specific category like a commercial paper
Sridhar Komalla: and worst scenario could be like, it is going into a commercial paper, but only of one or 2 companies. Okay, so ensure that the portfolio of this mutual fund liquid scheme is well diversified into different different types of instruments, and also in different different companies, which are, you know, issuing these type of instruments? Okay, so guys, to sum up, liquid funds are not risk free, but they are definitely low risk category of mutual funds.
Sridhar Komalla: The question is, where will I find out the portfolio of all these typical Liquid fund schemes? You do have a free website, moneycontrol.com, and you'll find the portfolio of each and every liquid fund in that specific moneycontrol.com. So be sure that you check out the portfolio and then only invest in liquid funds. Okay? So I hope you have got a very, very holistic approach about what is a liquid fund? What are the different types of funds meaning, and I hope you have gotten a good confidence about when you should invest in liquid funds.
Sridhar Komalla: And now that you have understood
Sridhar Komalla: a lot about liquid funds. Let us now understand how to invest in liquid funds in the more simplistic manner through the easy plan. Okay, so let's
Sridhar Komalla: log into our easy plan. App and
Sridhar Komalla: just for your understanding. It's an app through which your funds get saved in icici prudential liquid, mutual funds.
Sridhar Komalla: Easybot says, What's your name? I'll just quickly introduce myself.
Sridhar Komalla: Okay.
Sridhar Komalla: So it says that it's helping me to set a savings goal first.st Okay? So I feel this is very important. Your 1st step towards financial success is setting up a goal. That's what we are doing right now, let's say I want to save for
Sridhar Komalla: a vacation. Why not? Or an emergency fund? First, st because I think emergency fund is more important. So let's set up for that. How much you spend approximately every month. So let us say, I spend 20,000 per month. Okay.
Sridhar Komalla: so obviously for 3 months, I'll be spending 60,000 for 6 months. One lak 20,000, but I think that 3 months emergency fund should be good enough for me.
Sridhar Komalla: So let me give this as a target for my savings.